welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition aka the guy who
makes Chris Evans look like Chris Evans
and this video were breaking down
snowpiercer
the TV adaptation is just about to drop
so there's never been a better time to
revisit the movie and discuss all of the
ins and outs of it throughout this video
we'll be breaking down the film's
overall plot its many messages and the
overall meaning to its ending there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the film yet
and don't want anything ruined then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as we're gonna be doing breakdowns on
the show episode by episode and you
don't want to miss any of the coverage
anyway with that out of the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of snowpiercer
okay so snowpiercer is a high concept
post-apocalyptic film that not only
talks about our society as a whole but
how human nature and greed often get in
the way of doing the right thing
in the early 2000s global warming was
slowly starting to devastate the planet
and in an attempt to cool down the earth
scientists launched rockets into the
stratosphere this backfired and created
a frozen wasteland in 2014 that wiped
out the majority of the species those
that were able to board or snuck their
way onto a train built by a genius
engineer known as Wilford the Train was
built by the mechanical magnate to
circulate the world until the ice had
melted and humanity could venture back
outside and try to rebuild civilization
in some ways it's similar to Noah's Ark
there are a lot of biblical metaphors
laced throughout Wilford in some ways is
a God he's referred to as malevolent the
children study him in school and there's
almost a cult-like worship of him
Wilford is also omnipresent throughout
the Train almost able to see all and he
has created the ecosystem on board
providing all those with food water and
life Revolution is also a key word as it
not only highlights the movement that we
follow on the train but also the train
itself each time it comes full circle
it's known as a revolution and this is a
nice tie back to the overall plot itself
we pick up with the Train in 2031 and
see the
a structure that exists within at
firsthand through the eyes of curse
those in the tail of the train have had
to resort to cannibalism are punished
for speaking up and live day to day
obsessed with surviving the roms are
frozen and broken off as punishment
they're split apart from their families
and their children are abducted for a
purpose which I'll get into later
they're also fed protein blocks which we
discovered through the film are actually
made out of insects and if you are what
you eat then this definitely highlights
how the people that exist within the
tail of viewed their classes freeloaders
because they snuck onto the train
but righted by political figures and
undervalued
however we discover at the end of the
film that they provide an essential
service the film carries the message
that in the face of inequality all the
lower-class can do is revolt it's
something that definitely feels more
relevant today especially in the wake of
lockdown and we are often asked whether
the economy is worth more than human
life it's something that this movie
tackles with - and it becomes clear
throughout the film that those in the
tail are merely kept alive in order to
allow the rich to survive and keep the
train moving I'll get into this more as
we go further into the video but you
quickly realize that the top 5 and 1%
have basically imprisoned the lower
class in a system that they aren't
really able to rise up and escape from
there's a moment at the beginning in
which a violin player is requested to go
to the front
I think this symbolizes how those born
poor often only managed to escape it
through either theatrical talents or
sport it's very much a case of if you're
unable to entertain then you'll be stuck
in a prison in which you are solely used
as a commodity after another devastating
child abduction curtis's father figure
Gilliam decides it's time to start a
revolution they decide that in order to
control the Train they have to get
control of the engine initially there's
a lot of fear surrounding this and most
just want to mind their own business
preferring to live day to day rather
than sacrificing themselves for the
greater good I told you it was laced
with social commentary however after
they realized that the gods have no
ammunition due to having to stop so many
revolutions in the past they decide to
move forward they free a prisoner known
as Nam Geun a chronal addict that worked
as a security specialist on the train
before he was jailed
kronole is actually a drug used to
subdue prisoners on the
train and put them into suspension but
it was modified for street use and
passed down the tail namgoong becomes a
great ally and along with his
clairvoyant daughter jana the rebels
make their way up the train here they
notice an ice dub a plane that is
slightly visible whereas the year prior
it wasn't and this shows that the ice is
beginning to hunt though you really get
the feeling that Kurtis is willing to do
anything for his revolution and he even
sacrifices his friend Edgar in order to
capture a high-ranking official known as
Minister Mason Kurtis makes his way up
the train with Mason namgoong Yona gray
Tania and Andrew the latter of the two
had their children taking from them in
the beginning and their fate ties into
the end the movie is laced with
incredible action scenes as the rebels
make their way up the Train and we see
lavish carriages such as a Garden of
Eden like green house an aquarium
classroom and more the classroom is
indoctrinating the children and the
teacher their attacks the rebels in the
tale a staff member of Wilford known as
Franco executes Gilliam and angered by
this Curtis returns the favor by
shooting Mason the group go forward but
Franco catches up and shoots at them
from the classroom he stalks them and
kills tania and gray in a spar carriage
but namgoong fights with Franco and
seemingly manages to kill him Curtis
promises to find Tania's son Timmy and
they head upwards it's here that we
learn of Curtis is past and all the
things that he's had to do to survive
it's revealed that the talese resorted
to cannibalism in order to get by and
that Curtis almost ate Edgar as a baby
Gilliam gave Curtis his arm instead and
thus he was able to live I believe that
this metaphorically shows that those in
the 1% are willing to let those below
fight amongst themselves and literally
eat each other in order to take their
eyes off who's really in power they
can't fight those at the top if they're
fighting amongst themselves and it
definitely mirrors our society in
several ways it reminds me of how people
often blame immigrants those on benefits
and the lower rungs of society for being
the problem because that is what they're
fed by the press however these groups
often don't have any real power and
therefore we are pointing the blame in
the wrong direction
after becoming cannibals they were then
given protein blocks in order to be
thankful for the little crumbs that they
had whilst those further up the chain
still lived their lavish lifestyles the
survivors reached the last car before
the engine which is sealed but namgoong
manana revealed that chronal isn't
explosive and just as they're about to
blow up in a hole to the outside Wilfred
opens the door clawed one of Wilfred
staff shoots namgoong and Curtis goes
into the engine room to meet Wilfred
face-to-face it's here that we get the
big twist that really sends Curtis off
the rails I'm sorry you know how to do a
bad pun at least once
anyway the twist is that Gilliam was
actually working with Wilfred to cause
the rebellion this was in order to
reduce the population in the tale he had
allowed them to become cannibals to weed
them out and then allowed them to thrive
once more the Revolution was once more a
sacrifice in order to keep the ecosystem
alive
Wilfred enlisted Gilliam but really he
viewed him as replaceable as the rest of
those in the tail it's a middle
management scenario in which Gilliam was
given a tiny bit of power but in the end
he was just a puppet that suffered with
the rest of them believing he was better
because he had some authority
Wilfred argues that the people up top
are in just as bad a position as those
in the back and that every aspect of
society has its cons at the end of the
day how could he have it though all
depends on looking privileged
Wilfred then offers Curtis his position
allowing him to control the same system
that he fought against he paints out the
portrait that there's no other way than
what the system established and that
those must live in poverty in order to
support the important people of the
world
Curtis almost accepts this job until
riots forced Claude to check outside and
Yona overpowers her Yona rushes into the
engine room and reveals a floor panel
that has Timmy within it in order to
keep the engine going Wilfred has really
crossed the line children under five are
small enough to fit into it and they
used to keep the train going manually
could his rescue use Timmy at the cost
of his arm but it's clear that the
children there are very much brainwashed
into believing Wilfred side deals one
sacrifices themself in order to go into
the reactor and it shows that if you
teach children from a young age that the
system is supposed to be a certain way
that they will
follow it forever to me this reflects
how child labor is still used across the
world and we turn a blind eye to it
because it's part of the industries that
benefit us with material items Apple
Samsung and more have all been exposed
for using companies that thrive on child
labor but we still support them because
of what they've given us to make our
life easier this is very much what
Wilfred represents outside namgoong
kills Franco and they explode the
chronal on the door which sets off an
avalanche that derails the Train
namgoong and Curtis shield Timmy and
Jana from the explosion by wrapping
themselves around them and thus they're
able to survive because they sacrifice
themselves for the future ideals the
owner and Timmy are the only survivors
of the wreckage and they make their way
outside they don't instantly freeze and
die and they actually spot a polar bear
which shows that life is started to
return to the planet this means it may
be possible for them to survive but
there's actually a lot more going on to
me this is almost an Adam and Eve like
metaphor and they've gone forth into a
new world in order to create it to build
a new way of doing things they had to
bring the old systems crashing down and
this required revolution I'll sing those
in power and sacrifice
however they were able to accomplish it
the train itself in some ways can be
seen as a prison throughout the movie
those from the back move to the front
but ultimately they're still stuck
inside a train this is a metaphor for
how people can progress in society but
ultimately they're still stuck inside it
the children on board are told that if
they go outside they will die but
clearly this isn't the case we must
question that things that we are taught
and whether they're actually the truth
or not though the future for the two
initially seems bleak director bong
joon-ho confirmed that they do survive
and go on to repopulate the human race
this shows us that there is hope and no
change initially seems scary we can't
push ourselves through and make
something out of it now I don't know
whether we should start by tearing
everything down
but the last few months have really
opened my eyes to how broken everything
is we are willing to sacrifice those
that make up the majority in order to
keep our systems in place and it really
makes you question whether it's all
worth it
economies bounce back but as this film
shows human life if wiped out does not
we must truly find the value amongst
ourselves rather than in the system and
that's why snow pß still carries such a
strong message it's an incredible film
that feels even more relevant today than
it did with its release seven years ago
and I really can't get over just how
well-made this movie is I definitely
recommend it before you watch the
release of the show and hopefully this
video has given you a new appreciation
for it obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on snowpiercer
and what you took from the ending
comment below and let us know and I just
want to give a huge shout outs to bond
gaming who's helped us work on this
video and it's supported the channel for
a long time now definitely go check out
their channel and if you want something
else to watch after this then make sure
you check out our breakdown of all the
theories that we have for Westworld
season 4 which is gonna be linked at the
end if you want to support the channel
from his letters 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to evil day with heavy spoilers so
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe huge thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]